the Antonio Brown saga continues to
dominate in the NFL yep and the latest
development is a serious one and we're
gonna treat it that way we've got
several stories already a pro football
TOCOM that you can digest but the bottom
line is this last night at about 8:30
p.m. Eastern Time
story landed on the New York Times
website regarding a lawsuit filed by a
woman named Brittany Taylor in Florida
accusing Patriots receiver Antonio Brown
of sexual assault and rape three
different incidents in 2017 and 2018 the
2018 incident as alleged in the civil
filing the most serious forcible rape
refusal to stop even though she was
screaming and yelling for him to stop
that is the accusation in the civil
complaint Browns lawyer Darren Hytner
issued a statement not long after the
story landed on the New York Times
website denying everything
admitting however the existence of a
personal intimate sexual relationship
between Antonio Brown and Brittany
Taylor but calling the entire thing a
money grab so Chris look the one thing
we need to keep in mind no criminal
charges have been filed right it doesn't
mean they can't be pursued but the
standard in Criminal Court much higher
than the standard in civil court and he
could be found legally responsible for
these actions based on a very simple
5149 jury looks at him and here's what
he has to say and watches his demeanor
how he's testifying is he believable
does his story hold up jury watches her
does she seem believable credible
likable persuasive does her story hold
together both will be subjected to
aggressive cross-examination typically
the plaintiffs case will go first she
would testify before him although
there's always a chance and I've seen
this happen and I've done this where in
the plaintiffs case in chief you call
the defendant to the test to testify and
you launch right into an aggressive
kramat a cross-examination of him before
her story's even out there either way if
this doesn't get settled it's gonna end
up in court it's gonna be he said she
said and it can go either way and we're
at the very early
stage of this we don't know how it's
gonna unfold he has rights she has
rights and now we we just have to let it
all play out and as we've seen in plenty
of civil cases it can take months if not
years for it all to be resolved well
yeah it's the ongoing saga of Antonio
Brown and again yes we don't know this
is this is you know this is very early
stages we don't know whether he's guilty
not guilty at this point whatever it may
be the the first thing though that's
troubling to me is again as we're seeing
some of Antonio Brown for a few years it
was just craziness on the football field
and in the football facility but we're
seeing it filter over to issues in
everyday life and yeah again I don't
know if he's guilty if it's true or if
it's true if it's true it was just the
right to say that I don't know we don't
know anything at this point and we've
certainly seen some of these cases go
any either way so but you don't think
this is nothing that's going to get
settled through the courts anytime soon
to where the NFL is gonna be able to
make any judgments like Mike if he
settles out of court right and then just
like whatever has to pay or some money
because he doesn't want to deal with it
again don't know if he's guilty or not
guilty not saying that but he just wants
to doesn't can the NFL interject then if
he settles it outside of court and does
pay her does is there anything that
happens there well and here's the
problem as it relates to the NFL's
in-house system of justice there's no
subpoena power there's no way to force
anyone who isn't employed by the league
office or its various teams to comply
and cooperate with an NFL investigation
but the statement that was issued by
Brittany Taylor's lawyer to the New York
Times makes it clear she is ready and
willing to fully cooperate with the NFL
and the state that statement that was
issued by the New England Patriots late
last night has the perfunctory standard
language right we were we're not gonna
comment a further yada-yada but at the
bottom it says this the league has
informed us that they will be
investigating we will have no further
comment while that investigation takes
place so that statement and usually the
team's initial statement says nothing
this one says plenty because it tips the
league's hand the league will be
investigating and remember lis can
investigate the leak indiscipline even
without an arrest right Ezekiel Elliott
was never arrested he was never charged
he was never even sued for what happened
between him and his accuser but he ended
up being suspended six games by the NFL
and if the NFL is investigating this fir
is very easy the lawsuit is online you
look at the lawyers name you call the
lawyer up and say we'd like to meet with
Brittany Taylor it could be done by the
end of the week at least the initial
preliminary interview and then you talk
to Antonio Brown and it's in so my point
is this Chris yeah unless he swoops in
now and buys her silence which is
Edelman right yeah right and and gets
from her an agreement not to cooperate
with the NFL and that's perfectly
legitimate right he could write her a
check today that says we settle all
claims everything's over
and you agree not to cooperate with
anyone not to talk to anyone unless you
are subpoenaed by a court of law to do
so which the NFL doesn't have the power
to do it that if that happens right now
this all does go away and you know it
would have been smart look people get
falsely accused all the time you have to
set that aside and and make a business
judgment now he's got this complication
that has been thrown on top of
everything else he's trying to get his
feet wet with the New England Patriots
yes maybe there's a price out there that
he could have paid to as a business
transaction even if he believes the
accusations are false you get a
commitment from her that she is not
going to talk to the NFL as a business
proposition that is a much better
outcome than now having to deal with all
this uncertainty and this cloud that's
gonna hang over him as he walks through
the front door
for his first day of practice with New
England Patriots yeah I mean it's not a
good look it's not a good look for him
the New England Patriots anything like
that and I mean that's where I think
about it Mike I mean we're talking about
a guy who is hanging by the thread in
his business world as is I mean yeah
okay the New England Patriots we knew
that they might take a chance in San
Antonio Brown I don't know if they would
have done this if these allegations have
been made you know relevant before
before all this happened okay we heard
the Seattle Seahawks but those are two
unique teams that we know have unique
head coaches who are great at handling
certain personalities and they're not
Afraid of a character like Antonio Brown
because they've set forth a culture that
fits that and I just sit here with
Antonio Brown and have a hard time
thinking that they won't aggressively
try to do something today or something
on as far as a business deal to make
sure that this does not become
information the NFL or the public gets
ahold of and maybe just squash it he
might not like to have to write the
check he wants to write and I don't even
know if this the accuser is willing to
go down this path at this point but I
think just as far as Antonio Brown is
concerned that might be his best option
here because if this draws out and
starts to look ugly and things like that
people gonna go wait okay he's a pain in
the ass in the locker room in practicing
and now he's a pain in the ass outside
of the football facility and everything
that goes along with it now and he's
become there's become issues with the
law allegedly and all of that stuff to
where gosh nobody's going to want to
touch this guy with a ten-foot pole and
and Chris it's important for people to
understand that it's very common in the
legal profession for an effort to be
made to resolve cases like this before
they're actually filed and there
actually is settlement value look they
people call it extortion it's not
extortion if you have valid legal rights
that you are prepared to pursue in court
there is nothing wrong with approaching
the potential defendant ahead of time
especially when it is someone with a
high profile and saying we would like to
resolve these claims before we go to
court we have the right to go to court
we intend to go to court and we will go
to court if you don't resolve this and
there is extra settlement value in
keeping this from ever becoming a thing
and I can only assume that if you know
rational lawyers with a basic amount of
competence are involved here they did
try to settle it ahead of time and it
probably would have been a good idea
unless they want some exorbitant amount
of money it would have been a good idea
to make this go away because now you're
right people in New England are gonna be
looking at him a little more sideways
than it already would have been right
the front office has to be wondering
about this guy
whatever that last chance deal that he
was on it's a little thinner than it was
and you made great
point Chris and we'll never know the
answer this question if the Patriots had
known about this before it was time to
sign that contract right Antonio Brown
would they have yanked it and said sorry
we can't do this I think there's a
chance a what it said we can't do this I
think you're right I just don't think
they would want to deal with it you know
not right now especially hey I mean the
Patriots have not had the smoothest of
off seasons whether we talk about
ownership or Patrick Chung you know as
of late and again all those cases are
pending and I understand that you know
that nothing's been settled there but
you're right this is this is a hard one
and you know with the environment in our
country and everything the way it is
right now this is a course a sensitive
subject it's always a sensitive subject
but I feel like there's a little bit
more microscope under these type of
things right now in 2019 than ever
before and it's just a whole nother
level of you know media scrutiny and
being under a microscope for the New
England Patriots who we know just don't
like that and let me say this to the
extent that Antonio Brown had a very
carefully manicured and cultivated
approach to social media last week to
get his way out of Oakland if his
lawyers and Representatives sense this
thing was coming they should have taken
the initiative and told their story
before it appears that they're in
reactive defensive mode this is all a
very subtle PR dance and now it's out
there in the public domain and it adds
intense pressure on top of everything
else Antonia Brown is currently dealing
with now he's got this and again unless
I don't want to start throwing numbers
around because I don't know what would
be a fair outcome here because again we
don't know anything about the facts of
the case but if the allegations are true
it's a serious trauma that was inflicted
upon Brittany Taylor but the bottom line
is you set all that aside and you look
at it as a business transaction and
there is real value to Antonio Brown
today to have that lawsuit never be
filed and I don't care how aggressively
you're going to defend it it there's a
suggestion that he's gonna file a
counterclaim against her a countersuit
against her that would be a mistake that
just makes him look vindictive and mean
and if it all goes sideways in court the
fact that he sued her back is going to
make it even worse
all those strategies maybe you use it in
a normal case this is not a normal case
and if they could have kept this from
ever ending up in court
he'd be so much better off today because
everyone's gonna be talking about it
everyone's gonna be analyzing it and
everybody is going to have an opinion
about it whether they express it or not
in the New England locker room and it
just complicates his arrival his
official arrival for his first day of
practice as a member of the team yes
yeah it definitely does I mean you're
right everybody in the locker room is
gonna be looking at him through the side
eye a little bit right now cuz then you
know this is a level of dysfunction if
guilty where it just doesn't fly in a
locker room and there's gonna be a lot
of guys that I look at look at you and
never look at you the same the thing
that I thought it was interesting Mike
you said you know maybe it would have
been smart if they knew this was coming
to get out and in front of this right
they can't get out in front of it see
this is what happens when you lose the
benefit of the doubt and you do crazy
things in an organization and you do all
these crazy things a part of a football
team and oh now I might force myself out
of a place like Oakland or whatever it
may be
and on that hey everybody just what this
is all so what's going on outside in my
life right now I'm trying to fight this
and get out in front of it I mean it
just would have scared everybody off
completely so I think they are stuck in
a corner a little bit here and I'm gonna
be interesting to see how this all
unfolds let me think about it we are
five days removed just five days from
Antonio Brown standing up in the locker
room with the Oakland Raiders to
apologize for what had happened last
Wednesday now this Wednesday does he
does he address the team on the way in
hey I know you guys are aware of this
lawsuit that was filed against me I just
want to say it's fine I mean this is not
a good way for him to be starting his
career with the New England Patriot
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports